okay anthony edwards first off thank you
so much for joining me on
what is like one of the biggest times of
your life
when you wake up wednesday morning tell
me the first
thought that's gonna pop into your head
to be honest um probably gonna say i
gotta feed and walk my dogs
that's that's that's the first thing i'm
gonna say but as far as like basketball
wise i'm just gonna
i'm probably gonna pray and just
whatever happens happens i'm not even
gonna really think about where i'm gonna
end up just whatever happens supposed to
happen
you have said who wouldn't love to be
the number one pick so sell me
tell me why you deserve to be the number
one pick
i feel like uh i deserve to be the
number one pick probably mostly because
of the person i am off the court not
even on the court everybody i feel like
a lot of people know my abilities on the
court
just the person i am off the court like
just
always smiling i'm always happy and i'm
never a negative person so i just feel
like that
that sums it all up you know the top
picks obviously are expected to deliver
results
very quickly in what ways will you and
can you
impact the game immediately uh
just my play making ability my ability
to score the ball
my my ability scored by all three levels
uh
i feel like my uh defensive potential
yeah i mean i've watched a lot of
interviews that you've done recently and
you
always say listen defense is my thing i
can play defense why is it so important
to you to make sure like
teams and fans know that you could play
some d
uh i feel like because like it's a lot
of clips of college where i played
defense since a lot of clips where i
didn't play defense but i just want the
world to know like
that i really can't defend the ball like
i can play really good defense so
yeah i feel like we're gonna see nature
like if i stay engaged and locked in the
whole
time old 72 games people don't see
outrage how good my defense really is
now i'm giving you a chance to deliver a
message to the fan base of the team that
drafts you
you know you are now a part of this
family whatever team that is
what would you say to that fan base
please ready to
win a whole lot of games go to the
playoffs go to congress finals and go to
the finals
i love to get in touch with the crowd
and i love you know pump the crowd up
talk to the crowd so
y'all just be ready yeah who are you
most looking forward to
playing against when the season starts
almost definitely kevin durant
yeah you love kd you were talking about
him when we uh when we did that
interview
you're also saying like that is somebody
you have had some communication with
have you still yeah yeah yeah
yeah has he offered any good advice no i
won't
no yeah okay well i don't
know i gotta play against himself yeah
so you're right like he's competition
now
what's it gonna be like though so when
you step on the court you'll have to
separate you know the fact that he is
one of your favorites
uh i mean when i enter the league it's
not gonna be your favorite no more i'm
gonna be my favorite
but i when i wasn't in the league i was
he was my favorite but
once i did once when they come i don't
know i'm my favorite so
i'm not going to love this you're saying
everything right
i know that you got to speak with
michael jordan um and you said that he
gave you some tips on how to be more
efficient in the mid post
what were some of those tips i mean you
got basketball tips from the goat
oh man it was just mostly like just
you know use your butt more to post in
the mid post
so i feel like that was the best thing
he told me and he was like you are he's
like you're stronger than i
am you're more athletic you're bigger
than me
and he was just like use your butt more
and create more space
you're gonna be unguardable so i just
feel like hearing that was just which is
crazy because
he actually came to watch me work out
and gave me some tools to take with me
while
i keep working out so i feel like yeah
i mean for michael jordan to say like
you're stronger than me already i mean
how does that how does that even feel
you know to hear that and to know that
he sees this
potential uh i can't even describe it
that's just crazy yeah it was just crazy
him just being there
you know being a part of clutch sports
means you get to be around and learn
from a bunch of nba stars and leaders so
i want to talk about a couple of those
guys
tell me as specific as you can be what
have you learned from lebron
i don't talk to those the only person
that i talk to all the time is draymond
green
okay what have you learned from draymond
he just he just tell me like
just stay focused like no matter what
happened just stay focused
just keep working you tell me you be
like you got it all just keep working
stay grinding stay low ahead just keep
working your feeling
everything in front of you that's
probably the only thing all right now
last time i spoke to you it was actually
in the bubble when i was grabbing dinner
with some friends
and john morant was there and you guys
were facetiming i know you guys are
super close
what advice has he given you during this
pre-draft process
uh kind of the same thing he was just
telling me yeah he was just telling me
like
it was it's easy for him probably the
most he was just like
it's easy for me so it's not gonna be
hard for you it was like
you scored a ball at a high clip like i
said he was just like where you you can
score the ball so it's gonna be easy
like you get switches with bigs
it's not it's not as hard as people make
it seem
okay nice and last question for you i
know last time i talked to you
you love music so know what song
from 2020 describes you and your game
you gotta pick one low down by little
baby
okay why why low now i'm good pick but
tell me why
jacob me and the baby from the same
place you both from oakland city
and it's just you know it's
in jail i'm gonna be around each other
like we just you know what i'm saying
it's just
we're cool and i just i love music so
yeah i feel like lower down this is the
best song
well anthony it is amazing to talk to
you as always i am looking forward to
continuing to cover you through
a very long and prosperous nba career
and
most importantly best of luck i'll be
watching and i
i wish you the best thank you so much
good talking to you
good talking to you as always bye aunt